翻訳: Yuta Kawamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん
自分の周りにいま「ある」モノを
活かせていますか？
「もったいない」って言葉が
世界中で使われているように
物を大切にする意識が求められています
一方で リフォーム、リユース、リサイクル
いま「ある」モノを活かす技術やツールは
どんどん進化しています
僕たちは意識を持つだけじゃなく
技術やツールを駆使して
今あるものをうまく活かして生きていく必要が
あるんじゃないかなと思うんです
それでは皆さん
自分の中に
今「ある」モノを活かせていますか？
僕は全く活かせていませんでした
それどころか 自分の中には
何もないとさえ思っていました
高校時代 僕は一学年450人ほど生徒のいる
学校に通っていました
学校の成績は入学してから
ずっと400番以下でした
一度も浮上することなく卒業しました
大学受験はことごとく失敗
現役の時は１校も受かりませんでした
浪人しても大して成績は変わりません
10校ほど受験して
かろうじて拾ってくれたのは１校だけでした
仲間と比べて
「俺は頭が悪いな
どうせ俺には才能がないんだ」って
劣等感をたくさん集めてしまいました
その結果 自分には何もない
自信のない少年になってしまったんです
そんな僕が その後弁護士になって
今こうして皆さんの前に
立たせてもらっています
当時の僕には想像できないことでした
ある出会いをきっかけに
大きく変わることができたんです
僕が出会ったのはブレイクダンス
1970年代
アメリカ ニューヨークで生まれた
ヒップホップカルチャーの１つの要素です
2018年には16歳から18歳までの
若い世代のオリンピック
ユースオリンピックの
正式種目になることも決まっています
今や世界中の人達に
愛されるダンスになりました
少しだけ…
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
さて このブレイクダンスには
いろんな要素が求められます
ステップの技術、ミュージック
パワー、オリジナリティ
先輩からは「オリジナリティが大事だよ」って
教わりました
「お前らしさは何なんだ？」って
常に問われ続けました
でも先輩方は
オリジナリティの作り方については
教えてくれませんでした
僕はどうやったら自分らしくなれるのか
自分らしさはどこにあるのか
さっぱり分かりませんでした
僕は劣等感を集め続けていました
自分には何もない —
今の自分を否定していたんです
だから 「もっと勉強
できるようにならなくちゃ」
「もっと頭良くならなくちゃ」って
自分にない力を求めました
自分には何もないから
自分の外に答えを求めたんです
オリジナリティを追求した時も同じです
自分が本当にやりたいことではなく
自分の外に答えを求めました
例えば 流行に逆行してみたり
他の誰もやらない奇抜な動きを取り入れたり
自分が本当にやりたいことじゃなくて
周りを見て 周りの奴らと違う自分を
作ろうとしたんです
でも しっくりきませんでした
本当に僕がやりたいことは何なんだろうって
自分自身が
よく分からなくなってしまったんです
そんな時あるBボーイと出会いました
彼の踊りに衝撃を受けました
「Bボーイ」っていうのは
ブレイクダンスをする男子のことです
彼は世界トップBボーイの１人です
彼の体にはある特徴がありました
足が不自由だということです
子供の頃の病気で
足の成長が止まってしまったって聞いてます
世界トップBボーイと聞いて
一方で足が不自由と聞いて
頭の中に「はてな」が浮かんだ方が
いらっしゃるかもしれません
「どうやって トップBボーイに
なったの？」って
彼は逆立ちを武器に踊ります
逆立ちで軽々と
ステップを踏む踊りをするんです
そのパフォーマンスは圧巻です
足の成長が止まってしまった
という彼の特徴 —
確かに立って踊ると
ネガティブな特徴かもしれません
でも 逆立ちをする
どうなるでしょうか？
一般成人と比べて足の体重が軽いという点で
逆立ちに活かし得るんです
ここで 僕の大好きなBボーイの映像を
ちょっとご覧いただきます
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
彼は18歳で足を失いました
彼は 義足も外して
ありのままの姿で踊っています
彼のシルエットや動きのフォームは
決して僕には真似できません
義足を外した後の踊りに美しさを感じるのは
僕だけじゃないはずです
彼は失った力さえも
活かしているんです
彼らの踊りを見ると
僕は胸が熱くなります
踊りがどうこうというよりも
一見 ネガティブな特徴を背負いながら
自分の中に可能性を見出して
そして努力と工夫を重ねる ―
彼らの姿勢に感動を覚えるんです
僕は 彼の姿勢から学びました
自分の中に「ない」力を
追い求めるんじゃなくて
自分の中に「ある」力を
活かすことが大事だって
そしてポジティブな特徴のみならず
ネガティブの特徴も含めて
いま自分が持っている力を
活かすことが大事だって
僕は劣等感を集め続けました
だから僕の中にはネガティブな特徴なら
いくらでもありました
そんなネガティブな特徴が活かせるとすれば
僕の中にも「ある」かもしれない
そうやって僕の中の可能性を
信じられるようになっていたんです
外に向いていた目線が
自分の中に向けられるようになったんです
そんな僕は
ダンスに明け暮れていましたけども
ある出来事をきっかけに
本気で弁護士を目指すことに
なってしまいました
でも 司法試験をクリアするためには
大きな問題があったんです
小学校から大学を卒業するまで
学校の成績が悪かった僕
勉強が苦手でした
大問題です
勉強が苦手な理由
それは暗記が苦手なことにありました
暗記が苦手だったら
勉強うまくなるはずないでしょう
昔の僕だったら
そうやって自分にない力を求めて
例えば暗記術を
身につけようとしたかもしれません
でも僕は自分に「ない」力を
追い求めませんでした
知っていたんです
自分の中に「ある」を活かすことが
大事だってことを
ネガティブな特徴も活かせるってことを
僕は暗記が苦手も「ある」かもしれない
そうやって暗記が苦手な理由を掘り下げました
そして暗記が苦手な理由は
ごちゃごちゃ考えることに「ある」
っていうことに気付いたんです
例えば何か覚える時に
「そもそも 何で覚えないかんの？」
から始まって
「言葉遣い 何でこんなに難しいの？」とか
「さっきこの定義出てきたよね
何が違うの？」とか
ごちゃごちゃ考えるから
素直に入ってきません
でも このごちゃごちゃ考えることも
一見ネガティブに見えるけど
僕にとっての「ある」かもしれない —
そう考えることができるようになっていました
ちょっと待ってよ
「ごちゃごちゃ考える」のうち
「考える」ってのは
勉強に活かせるのじゃないか？
そこで僕は 勉強の時間から
一切暗記を排除して
全て考えるだけの勉強に切り替えました
例えば教授から
「この条文大事だから押さえなさい」
って言われたら素直に覚えません
「そもそも何でこの条文が
定められてるんだろう？」とか
「裁判所は何でこの言葉遣いを
あえて選んだんだろう？」とか
「この条文とこの条文の厳密な違い —
使い方の違いはどこにあるんだろう？」とか
ごちゃごちゃ考えるだけの勉強です
法律は言葉もむちゃくちゃ難しくて
めちゃくちゃ とっつきにくい学問です
だからすぐに結果は出ませんでした
でもごちゃごちゃ考えることは
苦じゃなかったんです
ずっとやってきたことだから
時間はかかりましたが
だんだんと法律の仕組みが
わかるようになってきました
ごちゃごちゃ考え続けた結果
浅い知識ではなくて
深い理解が身についていったんです
５年かかりましたが
なんとかギリギリ 司法試験に
合格することができました
自分に「ない」力を
追い求めたんじゃなくて
自分の中に「ある」力を
活かそうとしたことが
勝因だったと思っています
ある神経科学者が
「数学の能力が向上すると
脳の別の分野の活動が低下する
その逆もまた然り」
そんな研究結果を発表したそうです
つまり ある能力が低いということは
その裏側で脳の別の分野を活発に
動かしている可能性があるってことです
この説に従えば
僕は「暗記が苦手」の裏側で
考える力を活発に
動かしていたことになります
皆さんも もし 才能ないなとか
能力ないなって感じた時は
チャンスです
その「ない」の裏側に隠れている
新しい才能に出会えるかもしれません
「ない」の裏側には「ある」んです
ちなみに ちなみにですよ
司法試験 ー 弁護士を志そうと思った
ある出来事なんですけど
実は 当時の彼女に
振られたことなんです
（笑）
「あなたとの未来が見えません」
って言われたんです
「悲しい 悔しい 今に見てろよ」って
失った経験も「ある」んですね
弁護士になって 今でも
僕は自分の中の「ある」を活かすことを
ものすごく強く意識してます
僕にとっての「ある」は何だろうか？
いろんな喜びを与えてくれたブレイクダンスは
僕にとって大切な「ある」です
じゃあその ブレイクダンスは
弁護士業で活かせるんかという話です
「確かに宴会芸では
活かせるかもしれないよね」って
思ってくれる方もいらっしゃると思います
確かに活きるんです —
結構受けるんです
でもそれだけじゃありません
ダンスは裁判でも活かせました
この写真はあるダンスにまつわる裁判で
無罪を獲得した時の写真です
DJが音楽を鳴らして
お客さんが体を揺らすクラブ —
僕もよく通っていました
過去形ですよ
（笑）
クラブは客にダンスをさせる営業だから
許可なく営業しちゃだめだ —
いわゆる 風営法に違反したとして
あるクラブのオーナーさんが
摘発されてしまった事件の裁判です
僕は 僕のダンスの経験を
ぜひ活かしたいって思いました
そして自分から申し出て
弁護団に加えていただきました
裁判では僕は
クラブの重要性とかクラブの価値を
主張するパートを任されました
「クラブは 表現者にとって
新しい表現にチャレンジできる場だ」
「その表現に対するリアクションを
その場で直ちに受けることができる場だ」
「つまり表現者にとっては
表現の自由にとって重要な場所なんだ」
そんな法的主張をすることができました
まさにダンスの経験が
裁判で活きた瞬間でした
おかげで無罪が獲得できた
とは申しませんが
ちょっとは貢献できたと思っています
ちなみに このかっこよく写ってる
写真なんですけど
引きで見ると超内股なんです
（笑）
すげー緊張してたんですね
ちなみに僕がダンスを裁判で活かしたのは
偶然じゃありません
皆さん「カラーバス効果」って
聞いたことあります？
心理学の言葉なんですけど
例えば この中で
「絶対に赤を見ちゃいけません
赤色を絶対に見ちゃいけません」
「赤を見るのは禁止です」 って言ったら
赤が目についちゃうんですね
つまり ある物事を意識すると
その物事を探し出して
見つけることができるという理論です
僕はブレイクダンスをぜひ活かしたい —
そう思っていました
だからブレイクダンスを活かす場所を
見つけることができたんです
皆さんも 是非自分の中に「ある」を
強く意識してください
それを活かすことを
必ずその「ある」を活かす場所が
見つかると思います
皆さん それぞれの「ある」を
活かすことができれば
皆さん一人一人が輝きます
そしてそんな皆さんが
周りの仲間の「ある」を活かすことができれば
仲間の「ある」も輝き
仲間が輝きます
そしてチームが輝きます
さらに社会が輝きます
まさに『Seed』
[TEDxNagoyaUのテーマ]ですね
「ある」を活かす —
大切なのは
皆さんの中に既に「ある」ってことです
皆さんの「ある」は何ですか？
ありがとうございました
(拍手)